يمكن لـ CNN الآن الكشف عن الكلمات الأخيرة لجمال كاش
التي لا أستطيع التنفس.
تسجيل صوتي
للحظات الأخيرة المروعة لكاش في غضون
لحظات من خطواته المصيرية إلى
القنصلية kesaji يتعرف على شخص ما يسأل عن
سبب وجودهم هناك الجواب الذي
ستعود إليه وفقًا لمصدر CNN.
دبلوماسي ومسؤول مخابرات
يعمل لدى ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان ، كان كساجي يعرف أن
خاشقجي
يشعر بالقلق بشكل واضح ، ويرد أنه لا يمكنك
فعل ذلك لأن الناس ينتظرونني بالخارج
وفقًا للمصدر ،
وتنتهي المحادثة
عند هذا الحد.  وبسرعة كبيرة
يمكن سماع كيشوري يقول لا
أستطيع التنفس ويكررها مرة أخرى لا
أستطيع التنفس أنا ج  لا تتنفس ما يحدث ،
بيل العيون تدعي السعودية في البداية أن وفاته
كانت خطأ فادحًا.
يقول مصدر سي إن إن أنه من الواضح
من قراءته للنسخة أن
مقتله لم يكن محاولة تسليم فاشلة
لتنفيذ خطة مع سبق الإصرار
لقتل الصحفي ولكنها كانت كذلك  ما
يحدث بعد ذلك هو أمر مروع حقًا ، حيث
يسجل النص العديد من الأصوات والضوضاء ،
ثم يقول الصراخ من جمال مرة أخرى ،
ثم يتم تحديد الضوضاء المشتعلة على
أنها سيف ثم تقطع
صوتًا تحدده السلطات التركية
باسم د.  سالي محمد ألتا
بايكجي ، رئيس الطب الشرعي في
وزارة الداخلية السعودية ، يقول
إذا كنت لا تحب الضوضاء ، ضع
سماعات الأذن الخاصة بك أو استمع إلى الموسيقى مثلي
وفقًا للمصدر ميتريك ،
يبدو أن قائد الفريق يصنع
ثلاثة هواتف على الأقل  مكالمات أثناء
جريمة القتل إلى عدد من المسؤولين الأتراك
يعرفون أنهم في الديوان الملكي السعودي ،
لا يمكن سماع سوى الجانب الأحمر غير اللامع من
المحادثة ولكن لا
يوجد شعور بالذعر أو أن العملية
سارت بشكل خاطئ.
المصدر
يأخذ معنى أن رئيسك في العمل أو كبيرك في
العمل قد تم ، لقد اتصلت
سي إن إن بالمسؤولين السعوديين
للحصول على رد ممن وردت أسماؤهم في هذا
التقرير وقيل لهم إن
مسؤولي الأمن السعوديين راجعوا النص
والشريط ولا يوجد أي مكان فيهما.
أي إشارة أو إشارة إلى مكالمة
يجريها مصدر سعودي مقرب من
التحقيق السعودي يقول إن كلا من الناضجين
ونفى بيكجي إجراء مكالمات
هاتفية وأثناء  تقدم الفدية مسدسًا ممنوعًا
للتدخين يربط مباشرة ولي العهد الأمير
محمد بن سلمان بالقتل ،
ويبدو أنه يردد مشاعر السناتور ليندسي جراهام
بعد سماع تقييم وكالة المخابرات
المركزية لقتل يهود الكوشر.